[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro 17 8 culture au
programme aujourd'hui la chapelle royale
et le cabinet d'angle du roi viennent
d'être restaurés boiseries architecture
charpente dorures tous deux ont subi une
rénovation intégrale vous découvrirez le
résultat des chantiers mais aussi leur
histoire
clap de fin pour l'estival après 33 ans
d'existence le festival de musique de
saint gérand lessard est la ville
souhaite à la place proposé un nouveau
rendez vous musical saint germain en
live prévu pour le mois d'octobre
et puis avec la crise de sanitaires le
métier d'antonius a changé joueur
d'orgue de barbarie l'artiste souhaite
désormais les anniversaires par visio au
premier confinement il en a souhaité 70
et je vous le disais en titre les
restauration de la chapelle royale et du
cabinet d'angle du roi sont terminés
tous deux ont subi une rénovation
intégrale pour retrouver à leur éclat
d'antan
l'explication des travaux avec les
représentants des chantiers
une restauration intégrale c'est ce qu'a
connu le cabinet du roi cette année
architecture boiseries et ameublement ou
fait l'objet d'une rénovation ou d'un
nettoyage le bon esprit était dans un
état
boursièrement le salt et même pour
certains il présentait désordre et
pouvait y avoir des fondations
importante
quelques lacunes dans des parts indoor
mais également des parties sculptées qui
était lacunaire l'occasion de restaurer
le meuble emblématique de versailles
mobilier français du xviiie siècle le
bureau du roi
ce meuble a été nettoyé l'île n'avait
pas été démontés je pense depuis sa
construction
donc c'était une grosse opération qui a
été menée à paris dans ce sens qu'on
appelle au c2rmf centre de recherche et
de restauration des musées de france et
qui a nécessité au préalable des
analyses financé par mécénat rolex et la
restauration de la pièce a duré un an
historiquement louis 15 avait fait de
cette pièce à son cabinet de travail 757
établi c'est la pièce dans lequel le roi
travaille seul ou avec un secrétaire un
ministre ne s'est pas la pièce
officielle
c'est la pièce c'est le plus gros du roi
s'il si on peut employer ce terme
autre chantier de restauration qui vient
de s'achever après trois ans de travaux
celui de la chapelle royale
la charpente du bâtiment étaient abîmées
sculptures vitraux et dorures ont été
restaurés on a vraiment voulu porter
dans la restauration dans son ensemble
donc du faîtage couverture aux ornements
plomb et aux ornements de sculptures
dans que les statuts en elle-même ans
portait une restauration assez
conséquente également au total une
centaine de personnes s'est succédé sur
le site tant dans le chantier douze
corps de métiers différents
objectif restaurer le visuel d'origine
et de la chapelle la d'horreur n'a pu
été refaite depuis depuis 19 ans
20e c'est là aujourd'hui qu'on
redécouvre versailles sous vraiment à
l'inauguration que nous 14 a pu voir
lors de son règne
c'est le dernier projet du roi louis xiv
avec jules hardouin mansart architectes
privilégié du roi qu'elle semblait matic
de la chapelle les deux groupes sculptés
dangereux doré c'est les anges pour
redorer
et puis on peut voir on verra dans le
département c'est devenu le phare je
pense de versailles parce que à 20 30 km
on voit émerger cette dehors magnifique
coût du projet près de 15 millions
d'euros
une nouvelle plate forme musicale sur le
site des médiathèques de saint quentin
en yvelines mais aussi sur ordinateur
tablette ou encore portable musique me
permet d'accéder à de nombreux titres
musicaux
célia gars tongon soir bonsoir vous avez
téléchargé l'application
oui c'est fait sur donc tablettes
ordinateurs au mobile l'application elle
s'appelle musique ni pour bibliothèque
elle est gratuite pour tous les saint
quentinois et les adhérents monde et
médiathèque mais aussi pour tous les
travailleurs et les étudiants donc de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cette
plateforme musicale est l'équivalent de
spotify ou deezer on retrouve vraiment
dans tous les styles de musique de
toutes époques
bien de tous le tout ça va de gilbert
bécaud m'a pokora en passant par les
comédies musicales en passant par le sol
dans les dom sont on peut retrouver
aussi de la musique étrangère c'est pas
forcément que que des chansons
américaines ou anglaises ou en français
on trouve vraiment des choses des choses
très très particulière et donc célia
quel est le lien entre justement musique
midi les médiathèques
c'est une plateforme complémentaire 1 au
service de collection et des
médiathèques puisque vous pouvez
retrouver deux dans de nombreuses de
playlist qui ont été faites par les
bibliothécaires intégrer ensuite sur le
site des médiathèques de saint quentin
en yvelines a par exemple des titres
pour vous détendre par exemple comme la
chanson fly oeil de coldplay que l'on
peut écouter
[Musique]
tél
sélection 1 des meilleures bandes
originales de films le but de musique
mais aussi donc de diversifier l'offre
musicale proposée par les médiathèques
c'est vraiment l'idée de proposer de la
musique de d'une façon différente mais
vraiment en lien avec nos collections
c'est une façon de tout pas de
transmettre mais de partager en tout cas
avec les adhérents nos origines parce
que souvent c'est des pianistes qui ont
un sens voilà même même pour nous qu'ils
ont mais des chansons qu'on aime aussi
dedans mais ça permet de faire connaître
il est aussi possible de créer sa propre
playlist personnel il ne vous reste plus
donc qu'à vous inscrire sur le site de
la médiathèque rubrique musique en ligne
aussi vous avez déjà un compte adhérents
et bien tout simplement de télécharger
directement l'application de ville merci
célia gâte son goût d'avoir été avec
nous merci je vous en parlais tout à
l'heure l'estival le festival l'estival
de saint germain en laye sarr est à la
place la ville souhaite proposer un
nouveau rendez-vous à musicale saint
germain en live
benoît battistelli vous êtes avec nous
ce soir pour en parler bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes chargé de la culture à saint
germain en laye déjà pour commencer
pourquoi arrêter le festival l'estival
bien écoutez la la ville de
saint-germain-en-laye soutenu fortement
depuis l'origine le festival l'estival
elle a soutenu pendant plus de trente
ans mais on a constaté ces dernières
années certaines formes d'essoufflement
la dynamique initiale qui avait permis
de fédérer l'ensemble des acteurs
culturels s'est un peu estompée et donc
on a souhaité créer une nouvelle
dynamique
en créant ce nouveau festival charmant
donc il y aura bien un rendez vous
musical à cette année puisque le
festival est en préparation
en quoi il va être différent de cet
ancien festival
alors nous avons un triple objectif
le premier c
de proposer une offre musicale la plus
large possible
naturellement toujours les chansons
françaises et francophones mais sauce
mais aussi les musiques actuelles les
musiques amplifiées le jazz les musiques
du monde le et le hip-hop le rock la pop
les arts de la rue bref une offre
musicale extrêmement diversifié qui
permet de répondre aux loups et aux
envies de l'ensemble des fédérations et
c'est donc cette volonté d'ouverture sur
l'ensemble des esthétiques musicales qui
nous gouvernent la deuxième les deux
objectifs c'est de rassembler et fédérer
l'ensemble des acteurs culturels de la
ville non seulement évidemment les
équipements culturels municipaux le
théâtre avec ses différentes salles le
conservatoire mais aussi nos partenaires
publics
le château de saint germain et son
domaine le musée maurice denis qui
connaît pas pour lequel s'achève une
rénovation de très grande ampleur
et puis les associations culturelles et
artistiques de la ville que ce soit des
écoles de danse que ce soit des chorales
et puis naturellement la clé est une des
principales scènes de musiques actuelles
en ile de france et qui était un
formidable incubateur de jeunes talents
ce nouveau rendez-vous aura donc lieu au
mois d'octobre là vous en parliez qui va
s'occuper de l'organisation de la
programmation à ce que c'est justement
ces établissements culturels est ce que
ce serait un partenariat avec les
associations
ce train partenariat avec l'ensemble des
structures dont j'ai parlé effectivement
ne souhaitons aussi concentrée cette cet
événement sur 4 5 jours et nous prenons
le risque je dirais de lancer une
édition d'été cette année ce qui n'est
pas simple dans cette période de deux 2
contre 1 sanitaire diverses mais nous
l'idée c'est que ce soit un moment de ce
soit un moment de fête musicale excusez
moi soit un moment de fête musicale qui
va occuper non seulement les lieux mais
aussi je dirais l'ensemble de la ville
avec des spectacles gratuits dans les
jardins du château sur la place du
marché
et puis les bars les restaurants qui
dieu merci seront rouverts à cette
époque en octobre et bien pour pour
proposer des concerts et des spectacles
c'est vraiment un moment privilégié pour
lancer la saison culturelle de la ville
de saint-germain-en-laye et c'est pour
ça que nous avons choisi ce nom
saint germain en live saint germain
parce que c'est vraiment saint germain
qui va créer cet événement est là et
bien là
c'est un terreau musical bien connu et
qui signifie tout ce qui est je dirais
direct spontané c'est la vie quoi et
justement aujourd'hui où on en est dans
la préparation du festival est ce qu on
a une idée de comment ça va se dérouler
peut-être déjà de la programmation alors
on est en discussion avec toute une
série d'artistes
je peux vous citer par exemple des noms
comme gaëtan roussel fatoumata diawara
l'impératrice ibrahim maalouf transe
express grand corps malade et c'est dans
le voyez c'est très très variés on est
en train de finaliser les discussions et
nous espérons pouvoir annoncer et
proposer cette programmation dans les
toutes prochaines semaines
tapez merci beaucoup benoît battistelli
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir merci et
rendez vous en
jobs à saint germain en laye c'est noté
je le rappelle vous êtes chargé de la
culture à saint germain en laye
[Musique]
joueur d'orgue de barbarie avec la crise
sanitaire le métier dans tonus à évoluer
l'artiste travailler dans l'événementiel
mais aussi dans les ehpad avec le
confinement est bien en mars dernier il
a proposé de souhaiter l'anniversaire à
des résidents par skype au premier
confinement il y en a souhaité 70
aujourd'hui l'offre s'adresse à tous
regardé je lis le texte qui a été pour
présenter fin qui était demandée est
écrit par la famille ou par l'ami qui
envoie ce message je chante un bon
anniversaire je fait souffler la bougie
virtuelle et je chante une chanson le
bon répertoire qui a été choisi au
répertoire ça va de paire silva les
fameuses roses blanches jusqu'à
satisfaction des stones voilà en passant
par les rita mitsouko joe dassin et puis
des chansons de guinguette et chansons
plus actuel
[Musique]
on n'a pas beaucoup ce genre de mots
quand on est artiste mais j'ai souhaité
mettre une participation à hauteur d'un
joli bouquet de fleurs qui est qu en
général on livre alors au lieu de le
livrer un bouquet de fleurs eh bien on
me renvoie sur les offres internet pour
ramener du sourire joyeux joyeuse à
il va
joyeuse à divers à la une à la deux et
la trois et c'est la fin de ce numéro du
7-8 culture merci de nous avoir suivis
très bonne soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]